a république en marche ne disposera pas
la majorité des trois cinquièmes en
cumulant les 312 députés de l'assemblée
nationale et le nombre même si ça devait
être 90 mais ce serait ce serait
extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
deux sénateurs pour obtenir les trois
cinquièmes après effectivement il ya les
alliés il y a le groupe modem à
l'assemblée il y à l'est républicain
constructif à l'assemblée il ya le rds
eu ici à voir comment est-ce qu'il va y
arriver
moi je reste quand même assez réservé
sur tous ses pronostics je ne dis pas
qu'ils ont raison je ne dis pas qu'ils
se trompent 90 ça me semble
extraordinaire mais même même dans les
pronostics plus bas attendons quand même
de voir parce que comme l'ont très
justement dit je souscris à peu près à
tout ce qui a été dit par les autres
invités de ce plateau avant moi le sénat
présente parfois des surprises
ç'a toujours été une chambre
d'opposition que ce soit un gouvernement
de droite sous un gouvernement de gauche
le tempérament du sénat est historique
il a toujours été là d'ailleurs pour
cela même lorsque la droite était au
pouvoir et que le sénat était
majoritairement à droite il devait de
gouvernement devaient toujours composer
avec les opinions du sénat idem lors
pour la petite parenthèse de gauche
et à cela s'ajoute le fait que voilà ce
n'est pas une chambre qui est
directement élu par le peuple comprend
très rarement au président contrairement
aux députés et que en plus il se
renouvelle par moitié tous les trois ans
donc tout cela fait que les changements
existe sénat vous disiez tout à l'heure
est ce que le renouvellement s'arrête à
la porte du sénat non mais il est
beaucoup plus progressif que il ne peut
avoir
il peut se produire dans les autres
instances et c'est voulu
c'est pas ce n'est pas là un problème
c'est voulu il veut une chambre qui
tempère et qui effectivement renouvelle
progressivement là où d'autres se
renouvelleront plus spontanément